[Music]
good morning kids and welcome to today's
wake and bake I'm your host
the band in the Hat normally it's white
hat today it's black why formal why
golden calves that's right there they
are golden calves golden calves doing
our second one right here at La Presa
and uh we eat upstairs and then we come
down here and I meet all the golden
calves and interview them so all week
long you're going to meet uh the golden
calf
diners who came and I made them [ __ ]
hummus and a vegan cheese steak and [ __ ]
like that oh
like I don't think it was worth what
they paid but [ __ ]
this is worth at least a quarter of that
threw on some
you know [ __ ] they're gonna get some
free shirts and [ __ ] don't worry I'm
giving them weed as well don't look at
me like that they're gonna make out
especially because they watch you're
gonna meet all of them everyone's gonna
have their own personal [ __ ] show
don't look at me like that this golden
calves think they like it too it's not
just me and the money
fans like you're gonna see I'll ask each
one of them what they thought of the
golden calves experience that way you
won't you won't be so [ __ ] judgy
foreign
[Music]
to the second uh golden calves dinner
here at uh my home at La Presa tonight
we're gathering before the holidays with
these five five fine folks and they're
gonna eat the [ __ ] out of some hummus
and since last time people were like
hummus is the main course like what the
[ __ ] I added a main course we're gonna
do vegan cheese steaks all right but
first uh we've had some cookies we've
got some drinks we're gonna have some
smoke
she's coming up here that's where the
owl came [ __ ] right over and imagine
like something that big that close
it was insane but we get all sorts of
wildlife the deer up here coyote
um rats
um lots of [ __ ] squirrels oh my God
so I've played at the hummus we didn't
shoot me cooking on this because you saw
that last time but I cooked some fire
[ __ ] hummus amazing hummus did you
try my hummus yet
get in here
get in here woman try the hummus
we all know her oh it looks good all
right
three months down the road no hummus no
first hummus back
so you turn away from the camera to eat
it do you not want to be on camera
[ __ ] very subtle move we know that
the hummus is working for works for her
[ __ ]
um now last time we did this I got a lot
of criticism not from the guests mind
you for serving only hummus as a meal
I think hummus is a meal uh so what
we're gonna do is I'm gonna make an
attempt at uh vegan cheesesteaks using
uh
uh unreal Deli steaks and some vegan
provolone and I got some rolls in the
shed so if people are like I'm not vegan
you don't have to eat it take a bite
even or take it home I'll sign it
[Music]
Jenny goldfarb's unreal steak
that's the secret this [ __ ] tastes like
Steak-umms to me
stake him is kind of the root of all
cheesesteak the problem is well we'll
see it from vegan cheese doesn't get
very melty in my experience
what I'll do is
heat all this until the cheese gets
melty then flop it in one of those rolls
that seems like the plan
[Music]
ready to serve
get a few more [ __ ] doors why don't
you ready to serve
[Music]
uh movies cannabis so sorry
anybody interested
this is the chronicon Cannabis seltzer
this is Cherry
welcome everyone
thank you
for having me pleasure to you guys
here happy holidays yeah
[Music]
uh okay so we're here at the golden
calves in the second one uh here at La
Prairie so this is Bradley Bradley tell
them your name Bradley bassage here so
Bradley shows up
um about 20 minutes early yeah 25
minutes early and I'm going out for some
[ __ ] at Ralph's I've decided at the last
minute
hummus alone
is not a meal I only decided that
because people criticized me last time
not to guess mind you they seemed fine
with it but like Jordan Jen a bunch of
people were like you can't just serve
[ __ ] hummus as a meal as a hummus is
a meal if prepared properly and would
you agree Bradley my hummus thank you
delicious could be a meal by itself but
I hedge my bets I said you know what I
got a lot of uh Jenny goldfarb's unreal
Deli steak because I bought like [ __ ]
20 pounds of it so I was like I'm gonna
make some cheese steaks man I went and
had to go get some hoagie rolls and had
to go get some vegan cheese so as I was
leaving the house there's Bradley
I said you you for me he's like yes get
in and we got in the [ __ ] vehicle we
went uh to Ralph's what was the shopping
experience
with Kevin Smith like here I'm gonna ask
you this how fast was I moving oh he was
moving and I walked past but he was like
blowing me away I was I was as I was
moving I was like don't forget you've
got a passenger there's a POV but I was
smoking through I'm used to moving like
a fish through a [ __ ] grocery store
and getting the [ __ ] out and [ __ ]
um we went and got our supplies
jump back in the vehicle came back
everyone was here already hey man it's
me Kevin Smith look at me my funny goofy
hat don't I look like hella from Thor
don't you sometimes want a club that
Kevin Smith well how about instead you
join that Kevin Smith Club oh my God
we've been having such a good time we
have hours of audio kids in this podcast
podcast archives that you can stick into
your ear holes and listen to or if you
want to look at something are you one of
them dirty [ __ ] well then go to the
Smithsonian screening room where you can
watch hundreds of hours of video of my
entire career spanning from the
beginning up till now including my daily
Morning Show wake and bake man where we
just smoke weed hang out and I tell you
what I'm working on plus there's
exclusive events we've had clerks three
screenings for our club members we've
had smod Castle exclusive shows for our
members back in Jersey we do events all
the time including movies pop-ups and
there's tons of merchandise of course
that that Kevin Smith club members get
exclusive access to before anybody else
there are so many ways into that Kevin
Smith Club ladies and gentlemen you
don't have to come through front door
you can come through the back door we
like it that way sign up as a clerk
where you get access to all the audio
that we got or join as a mallrat that
gives you all the audio and all the
video as well or join as a fun ployee
ladies and gentlemen you'll get a new
t-shirt an exclusive that Kevin Smith
Club t-shirt every quarter or join as a
yoga hoser and get yourself something
cool like that Kevin Smith wake and bake
Bowl ladies and gentlemen those are
existing levels but what about the new
levels that's right for 2022 we've added
some levels including the fashionable
mail you get everything that the clerk
the mallrat the yoga hoser and the fun
employee gets but you also get once a
year an exclusive piece of Wardrobe from
a Kevin Smith film straight out the
viewsk universe from the secret stash
archives or join as a brand new ranger
danger man that gives you everything
that the clerk them all wrap the fun
employee and the yoga hoser gets as well
as what the fashionable male gets but
then you also once a year get an
exclusive prop direct from one of my
movies and if you've got Untold riches
coming out of your ass guess what holy
cow there's the golden calves level man
for that level you come to my house I
cook you dinner we record a podcast and
we shoot it for wake and bake and it
goes up on smodcast man very exclusive
once a year we do that join us at
thatchevinsmithclub.com be a clerk be a
mall rep be a fun employee be a yogos or
be a fashionable male be a ranger danger
or be a golden calf ladies and gentlemen
I'll be waking and baking for you come
join me at that Kevin Smith Club
tap tap
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]